on va jouer à un jeu il s'appelle le
d'hingham bouffe direct il va peut-être
faire gagner un cadeau à tout le public
c'est un jeu je vais avoir besoin de
deux chroniqueurs
je vais prendre les deux chroniqueurs
tout de suite il faut deux chroniqueurs
de même corpulence
donc je vais prendre lassalien fabien
lecoeuvre et passe maintenant ils sont
bientôt niqueurs ne même pas qu'ils ont
pu et je vais prendre je pense je vais
prendre
allez je prends de jean michel maire
était mon ami non mais il est beau il
est beau je prends de benjamin castaldi
voilà voilà 3 la fin du tout c'est très
beau je vais prendre benjamin castaldi
et je vois bien raymond sais pas ils ont
à peu près la même corpulence genève âge
y en a juste un rien ajustant laon la
pesée avec moi regardez regardez
l'exemple
ellen degeneres qui l'a fait aux états
unis aient regardé et je vais vous
expliquer comment le public va gagner à
poux le tout le monde fasse gagnacais de
regarder d'abord regarder l'extrait
c'est parti attention vous avez compris
le principe mais ça donc on a tâché les
deux chroniqueurs parlement enfin ils
sont déjà attachés par le bras tous les
deux on leur a bandé les yeux et tour à
tour ils vont devoir reconnaître s'il ya
sous la coff uniquement et faire deviner
à l'autre ce qu'ils viennent de goûter
sans dire ce que c'est évidemment
d'accord pas donné le nom d'accord si
vous goûtez excès des frites vous dit à
l'autre c'est quelque chose à base de
pommes de terre
à laval on voit la fin comme le zizi de
mathieu mariolle des scouts exactement
il ne sert pas toi protection très calme
et vous les deux et les chérit les deux
chroniqueurs avoir deux minutes pour
faire deviner les dix plats ou s'ils y
parviennent
je vous le dis tout le public gagnera un
magnifique cadeau je vous dévoilerai
dans un instant s'ils n'y parviennent
pas bien entendu le public sortira
repartira chez lui et ne gagnera plus
aucun cadeau de toute leur vie
[Applaudissements]
le sens du public est entre la bouche de
castaldi d'accord et la bouche de
raymond avec les petites opérations vous
avez fait vous avez toujours du coni bas
à gauche au top alors il va aller là-bas
c'est bien tu as tu sais ce que tu fais
de toi tu vas tu douaniers des rêves
alors fait à base de pommes de terre
t'as pas de bonnes choses et le pomme de
terre ici et c'est mou seymour de la
purée wayne est un bon jour est c'est
parti à aller vite alors vite
ah ça c'est comme un yaourts desserts
c'est comme un dessert c'est vrai ces
données en dessert sur les cartes à la
fin du dessert des fois on dit on dit
c'est assez influent non autre chose au
coude renoir dessus des foires ah oui
c'est un tir ami joubran non pas les
hommes et sur quelques bonnes choses et
pas du tout ça supplément baffoni g
prendre un supplément
oui oui le supplément j'en suis sûr
bisous merci à dieu à lyon est revenu
les mots visa d'or c'est à base de miel
c'est les petits ronds un ouais ouais
ben ali ah oui et puis même à neuf
d'où la création à des petits ronds mais
pas chez vous paris des badauds un
rappeur fait quoi mais c'est quoi
maintenant milliards et le mec a peur
d'eux a alors à beat hefti votre petit
poisson avec du poisson de t'accompagner
avec coixet du poids lourds y voilà mais
non mais douteuses mais qui suite à ses
amis il est d'ailleurs n'a pas de goût
vous malgré deux mais nan mais c'est de
la pâte et du sud baitha pas que c'est
une quête vous mettez du sur deux fronts
les nuls
alors elle s'énerve quand même et d'y
aller qu'est ce que c'est moche le plus
soin du couscous web
[Applaudissements]
à l'ailé alors ça ne mange pas c'est
quoi alors ça se met au pied oui ça joue
au pied et parfois ils ont lésé scratch
way pour les fermer ça va bien
d'ailleurs fois attention je vous dis
pour l'instant ses pairs du jeu mais
c'est une guerre d'ajouter 30 secondes
et provoquerait redécouvrir les deux
derniers plat d'accord les deux avants
plan propose ci s'est pas découvert le
public
je suis choqué le spectateur j'ai un
huissier de justice qui est là je
pouvais faire tout et n'importe quoi non
mais ça y est je peux faire ce que je
veux mais noyé il ya m 4 lounes arrêter
là il ya une année bizarre oui oui mais
il ya m car le cayla qui est en régie je
ne bois vers n'importe quoi donc là on
me dit je peux rajouter 30 secondes
accord dont deux derniers plat mais
attention sinon je perds tout tout tout
et tout mais elle va démarrer parvenir à
venir ipad ou parce que vous êtes
meilleurs sais même pas ce que c'est moi
allez vas-y bastoche oh là là alors
c'est fabriqué par les abeilles et le
miel
bravo allez allez un dessert c'est un
dessert ou la décennie de la frnb comme
des brownies on met quoi dedans les
brownies au chocolat voilà c'est ça
[Applaudissements]
comment c cnet com ou des comores mais
cela vous sont chers
c'était de la mousse au chocolat
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
récit
[Applaudissements]
non
le cadeau tout le public cannois repas
pour deux personnes dans un restaurant
magnifique j'adore en plus habiles font
des cocktails magnifique si vous aimez
bouffe les fruits et le paradis dormant
vous adorerez ce restaurant
[Applaudissements]